coucou bonjour à tous Voilà c'est juste
pour vous montrer que je vais très bien
il semblerait que j'ai fait un accident
peut-être que cette rêve je ne sais pas
voulu par la personne mais
malheureusement pour elle ben voilà je
suis très bien je me porte très bien je
suis au Sénat pour travailler pour
l'aiguille à net puisque hier soir
j'étais en rendez-vous avec la ministre
chargée de la petite enfance pour
justement travailler sur les dossiers
épineux de la petite enfance et voilà je
suis là je vais très très bien ma
voiture n'est pas réformée elle roule
très bien et je suis navré en tout cas
d'apprendre cette nouvelle aux personnes
à là ou aux personnes qui auraient
souhaité me voir coucher à l'hôpital
comme vous le comme vous pouvez le
constater je n'ai pas gratuit je n'ai
absolument rien alors par contre de
arrêter de mentir arrêtez de mentir
quand on ment sur quelqu'un on met la
personne sous la lumière en tout cas
voilà ce que je voulais partager avec
vous et je rassurer aussi toutes les
personnes qui m'envoient la vidéo qui
m'envoient les captures de textes pour
leur dire que je vais très très bien
c'est passé une bonne journée